[music playing]
We're here at Speed Week
at the Bonneville Salt Flats.
This place is huge.
There's all kinds of extreme
machines here, not to mention,
its fair share of
just cool ass cars.
Dude, get that pickup truck.
Yeah, old Ford, huh?
It's like a '27, '29, '30?
That thing is cool.
That's probably
the rig they brought
out here to drive around.
Oh, just to
drive around, yeah.
Oh, wow.
Old school Studebaker, dude.
And there's the stock one
sitting right in front of it.
Look at that.
That used to be that.
That's a different year, but
they're pretty much the same.
And this is a sought after body
from the factory, aerodynamic,
made for Bonneville.
How are you doing, bud?
I'm Ryan.
- Ryan?
Shawn.
- I'm sorry.
I didn't mean to stop
you from working.
Hi, Shawn.
Kevin.
Kevin, nice to meet you, man.
Shawn, you got a minute
to talk about your ride?
Yeah, sure.
I was telling Kevin how this
body style Studebaker is sought
after for basically one of the
first streamlined door slammers
from the factory
made for Bonneville.
You look at a
'53 Studebaker, you
look at a '53 Chev,
or a '53 Ford,
look at the front end of them.
- Oh, yeah.
The Chevy or the
Ford is like a brick.
- Yeah.
They were way
ahead of their time.
What stock motor did you
say would be in this one?
289.
Like a little 289?
The Studebaker 289,
not the Ford 289.
Now I know there's not a
stock 289 that's still sitting.
Do you mind if we
look under the hood?
No, sure.
You give me a hand
lifting it off?
Oh, hell, yeah.
Well, hat's off
on the color, man.
It really is beautiful.
- Thanks.
It's a classy color.
It stands out, and
it's still classy.
Wow.
Yeah, that's not a 289, Ryan.
Oh, what motor's that?
- 515.
What's the horsepower
putting out on it now?
1173 flywheel,
about 990 rear wheel.
Wow.
That's over 1,000 horsepower
in this little car.
Yeah, that's amazing.
The car still
holds a record today.
What was the record?
240.
240 in a door slammer.
Wow.
- We're going to be chasing 250.
- 250.
John, man, good
luck out there.
Well, thank you.
I hope you get the record.
I appreciate it.
This is one bad car, dude.